the jurgen experience
the point is at some point he goes maybe
you could talk to joe rogan i'm like all
right you you just saw me as a conduit
to get the word out
oh you it's happened since the man show
days not nearly as bad as [ __ ] johnny
depp now where people you have to get
this to johnny like i'm not that close
to friends where i just hey johnny
here's an email of someone who wants to
buy you a home-cooked meal if you're
ever in [ __ ] ass
cancer nebraska but you back in the
[ __ ] man show days joe won't respond
to my emails
please tell him and then i would i would
tape the i'd have the email printed off
and tape it to the outside of my office
door for you
we showed uh your article that you had
written a bunch of years ago about amber
hamburg blackmailing johnny
and i remember you connected me to him
on the phone and i talked to him on the
phone yeah we were pretty [ __ ] up yeah
i shouldn't say that there's a subpoena
i was drinking margaritas on the beach
you're in hawaii and we were on [ __ ]
johnny depp island how about drinking
margaritas and i got my wife i'm holding
the phone i'm on the phone with johnny
depp
thompson from the movie
he does that sometimes i think his
monologue may have affected his did you
watch any of the trials i've watched all
the traffic have you so you watched the
pool part yeah i watched the poop we
were [ __ ] dying like it was a comedy
show when we're watching at the house
when he's saying that she tried to blame
dropping a grumpy
how do you know it wasn't uh a dog feces
how do you know it was
human feces and not your dogs
um
they're a teacup yorkies they weigh
about four pounds each
i've picking i've picked up their fung
before yes fung
a word i've never heard oh my god it's
well first of all what you get out of it
is that you know he is an actor and he's
very charming but he's also clearly a
nice guy he's a [ __ ] one of the
sweetest people i've ever met i 100
believe that i briefly said hello to him
in the backstage of the main room i
didn't really have a conversation with
him until you connected me with him on
the phone he's a sweet guy
you